اذا حزب الله اعلن قبل حوالي نصف ساعه
بانه استهدف ثكنه برانيت بصاروخ فلق ما
الذي نعرفه عن هذا الاستذ في
الاخير نعم في الواقع جلال ما شهدته
الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان اليوم هي تطورات
كبيره ينبغي قراءتها بتان لانها تتقاطع
فيها وعندها مارات متعدده اليوم حزب الله
ينفذ 10 عمليات وهذا الرقم مرتفع مقارنه
بكل ما كنا قد شهدناه خلال الاسبوعين او
الاسابيع الثلاثه الماضيه وليس الموضوع
يرتبط فقط بعدد العمليات ولكن طبيعه
الاسلحه التي كشف عنها حزب الله وال والذي
استخدمها في هذه العمليات العسكريه سواء
لناحيه صاروخ فلق او صواريخ بركان هذه
الاستخدامات المتعدده لهذه الصواريخ بزنه
حربيه تصل بالنسبه لصاروخ بركان الى نحو
طن من الراس المتفجر اما بالنسبه لصاروخ
فلق فهو صاروخ موج وجه ويحمل 50 كغم من
المواد المتفجره هنالك دلالات متعدده لهذه
الاستخدامات ولهذا الاشتعال الذي شهدناه
على الجبهه اليوم وخلال الايام الثلاثه
الماضيه وذلك من اعالي تلالك فرشو ومزارع
شبعه وصولا الى راس الناقوره والموقع
البحري هناك العمليات كانت عديده كثيره
والاستهداف كبيره هنا لابد من الحديث عن
مسارات متعدده دفعت بهذا التصعيد الكبير
سواء من ناحيه حزب الله او لناحيه
الاعتداءات التي تمارسها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على العمق اللبناني في المسار
الاول ما يحصل هنا عند هذه الجبهه بطبيعه
الحال لا ينفصل عن تطورات قطاع غزه المسار
المسار الثاني يرتبط بال التطورات
المتعلقه بالمفاوضات
وبمساعده على مستوى العمليات العسكريه في
جنوب لبنان اما المسار الثالث فيرتبط ايضا
بما يعرف باليوم التالي على مستوى الجبهه
الجنوبيه للبنان في ظل كل تلك التهديدات
التي وصلت الى القياده الرسميه اللبنانيه
من جهه والتي وصلت ايضا واطلقت القيادات
الاسرائيليه القيادات الاحتلال وبالتالي
انطلاقا من كل هذه المسارات وتقاطعاتها
يمكن ان نفهم الاسباب التي دفعت حزب الله
الى تصعيد هذه العمليات من خلال اختيار
تنفيذ عمليات ال نوعيه على المستوى السلاح
المست
لناحيه كشف هذه الصواريخ والاصرار على
استخدامها والاعلان عنها باسمائها وايضا
فيما يتعلق بالمساحه الجغرافيه الواسعه
واستهداف مجموعه كبيره من المواقع
العسكريه على طول الخط ضمن القطاعات
الثلاثه لجنوب لبنان في الشرقي في الاوسط
وايضا في الغربي